Traductor: Florencia Pons
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En 1968, el Dr. Robert Ho Man Kwok enfermó
luego de cenar en un restaurante chino.
Escribió una carta detallando sus síntomas
a una respetada revista médica,
reflexionando sobre si su enfermedad
derivaba de comer glutamato monosódico,
también conocido como MSG.
La conexión entre su dolor de cabeza
y este condimento muy común
en la gastronomía chino-estadounidense
fue solo una corazonada.
Pero su carta cambiaría drásticamente
la relación de todo el mundo con el MSG,
provocando pánico internacional,
sesgos en la ciencia,
y periodismo sensacionalista
durante los siguientes 40 años.
Entonces,
¿qué es este misterioso condimento?
¿De dónde viene?
¿Es realmente malo para ti?
El MSG es una mezcla
de dos moléculas simples.
El sodio, que constituye una parte
fundamental de nuestra dieta
y el glutamato, un aminoácido muy común
que se encuentra en varias proteínas
vegetales y animales.
El glutamato juega un papel clave
en nuestra digestión, función muscular
y sistema inmunitario.
En la época de la carta del Dr. Kwok,
fue identificado como una parte importante
de la química del cerebro.
El cuerpo produce suficiente glutamato
para todos estos procesos,
pero la molécula también
está presente en nuestra dieta.
Puedes notar su sabor característico
en distintos alimentos,
como champiñones, queso, tomates y caldo.
La búsqueda de este delicioso sabor
llevó a la creación del MSG en 1908.
Un químico japonés
llamado Dr. Ikeda Kikunae,
estaba intentando aislar la molécula
responsable de un sabor único
que llamó “umami,” y que significa
“un sabor agradable y sabroso”.
Hoy en día, el umami es reconocido
como unos de los cinco gustos básicos
en la ciencia de los alimentos.
Cada sabor básico se produce
mediante mecanismos moleculares únicos
que no se pueden reproducir
combinando otros sabores conocidos.
En el caso del umami,
esos mecanismos aparecen cuando cocinamos
o fermentamos ciertos alimentos,
descomponiendo sus proteínas
y liberando aminoácidos como el glutamato.
Pero Ikeda encontró un sabroso atajo
para producir esta reacción química.
Al aislar grandes cantidades de glutamato
de un tazón de caldo de fideos
y mezclarlas con otro potenciador de sabor
como el sodio,
creó un condimento que aumentaba
al instante el umami de cualquier plato.
El resultado fue un gran éxito.
En la década de 1930,
el MSG era un alimento básico
en la mayor parte de Asia;
y a mediados de siglo XX,
formaba parte de la producción comercial
de alimentos en todo el mundo.
Por eso, cuando se publicó
la carta del Dr. Kwok
el escándalo fue inmediato.
Los investigadores y los ciudadanos
exigieron investigar científicamente
al popular condimento.
Pero esto no era descabellado.
La sustancia no había sido probada
para determinar su toxicidad
y sus efectos en la salud
eran desconocidos.
Aun así, es probable que muchas personas
no reaccionaran a la falta
de seguridad alimentaria,
sino al título de la carta:
“Síndrome del restaurante chino”.
Si bien el MSG se usaba regularmente
en un gran número de cocinas,
muchos estadounidenses
tenían prejuicios de larga data
contra los hábitos alimentarios asiáticos,
etiquetándolos como exóticos o peligrosos.
Estos estigmas aumentaron
el sesgo racial en el periodismo
y difundieron el temor de que comer
en restaurantes chinos puede enfermarte.
Este informe prejuicioso se extendió
a varios estudios sobre el MSG y el umami,
cuyos resultados fueron
mucho menos concluyentes
de lo que sugerían los titulares.
Por ejemplo, cuando un estudio de 1969
descubrió que inyectar MSG a ratones
dañaba gravemente la retina y el cerebro,
algunos medios de comunicación difundieron
que comer MSG podría causar daño cerebral.
De manera similar, aunque algunos estudios
informaron que el exceso de glutamato
podría causar problemas como el Alzheimer,
luego se descubrió que
estas afecciones eran causadas
por desequilibrios internos de glutamato,
no relacionados
con el MSG que ingerimos.
Estos titulares no fueron solo
producto de reporteros prejuiciosos.
A finales de los 60
y principios de los 70,
muchos médicos también consideraban
que el “síndrome del restaurante chino”
era una enfermedad real.
Afortunadamente, los investigadores de hoy
ya no juzgan a este condimento
de manera discriminatoria.
Estudios actuales han establecido
el papel vital que desempeña el glutamato
en nuestro metabolismo.
Incluso, algunos investigadores consideran
que el MSG es una opción más saludable
a la grasa y el sodio agregados.
Otros están investigando
si el consumo regular de MSG
podría estar relacionado con la obesidad
y si es posible que el consumo compulsivo
de MSG produzca dolores de cabeza,
de pecho o palpitaciones cardíacas
en algunas personas.
Pero para la mayoría de los comensales,
una cantidad moderada
de este sabroso condimento
parece ser una forma segura
de hacer la vida un poco más sabrosa.